what's better being a cowboy or a pirate  oh man that's a that's a good question  that is a really really good question i  was born like when i was like six years  older yeah  this is a great  i love this question because i love both  of these characters i always wanted to  be a pirate you know what i mean you  [ __ ] steal [ __ ] you own a ship you  know what i mean  no one tells you where to go you just  [ __ ] go wherever you land you take  or a cowboy that's pretty badass  get the eat chew  god [ __ ] you yeah yeah and then you get  to kill yeah you know what i mean what i  owe you how much [ __ ] you  right  i would say cowboy yeah yeah cowboy i'd  be a cowboy all day  yeah hands down